Before AI and technology, people could
sit outside, write, read, and come up
with ideas. Now we can't think without
prompting a machine. So, here are five
things I do to make my life more free
from AI and tech. Number five, I manage
my tasks with paper and pen. No Asana,
Trello, or anything like that. Just
write your tasks down and do them.
Number four, I write on a typewriter. I
bought this cool typewriter from
Freewrite. Once I'm done with my
writing, I hit send and it goes straight
to my computer. Number three, I wear
wired headphones. You know the ones that
you have to like plug in and they have
no Bluetooth or radiation in them? Yeah,
those ones.
Number two, [music] I wear an analog
watch. Doesn't have notifications, it
doesn't track anything, it just tells
the time. [music]
And number one, I only study physical
books. I even print newsletters,
articles, and courses and read them
offline. What have you done to make your
life a little bit more tech and AI free?
Drop a comment down below, let me know.